une nouvelle émission qui vient de
sortir ça s'appelle top chef je sais pas
si vous avez vu 10 septembre 2010
cyprien marche tranquillement dans la
rue au même moment un astéroïde menace
de s'écraser sur la tête une mesure
n'est prise par les forces dirigeantes
qui n'ont pas été prévenus à cause d'une
erreur d'inattention
heureusement elle se dégrade dans l'air
pour ne devenir qu'une poussière qui
entre en contact avec un cheveu gras de
cyprien et par une réaction moléculaire
qui va vous expliquer maintenant associé
à une facilité scénaristique une faille
spatio temporelle est créé qui propulse
cyprien plusieurs années en avant et ça
il n'en saura jamais rien je suis
atteint de la malédiction top chef c'est
à dire que le soir de la semaine où je
mange le plus de la merde c'est le soir
où il ya top chef
bon je crois ce soir moi j'ai pris tous
les restes de la semaine j'ai émis dans
un tupperware je mets un petit peu d'eau
au micro ondes ça fait une sorte de kish
voilà pour le port on a des croûtes de
pizzas
[Musique]
ils vous font exprès ils le savent c'est
pour nous dégoûter de mal manger
laissez moi manger de la merde
tranquille un truc et fo avec top chef
dès le début en fait c'est le générique
du début avec la tête de tous les
candidats
vous devrez enlever le visage des
candidats qui sont éliminés au fil des
semaines
ça paraît évident isolé mais c'est pas
bob 1 pour vous la voiture s'arrête ici
du coup c'est possible de m'enlever du
générique ou là pas du tout pas du tout
va montrer votre visage chaque semaine à
des millions de téléspectateurs qui se
dérobe [ __ ] mais j'ai aucun souvenir
de ce type nickel c'est sa top chef
franchement les mecs qui font l'émission
waouh franchement bravo parce que c'est
bien c'est super bien rythmé déjà la
musique la musique vous avez entendu la
musique qui met un top chef m6 on
regarde pirates des caraïbes non je
regarde un mec qui coûte des ports où il
se passe quoi cette année ils ont ils
ont changé presque toujours les bordels
thierry marthe y'a plus qu'à y marque
mon préféré en bois il est parti pour
des nouveaux projets pour des trucs
gastronomie culinaire super pointu à mon
avis qu'ils le prennent beaucoup de
temps c'est sûrement ça
[Musique]
lustucru comme un chef les pattes qui
vous donne envie de les cuisiner comme
un chef est le seul membre du jury qui
reste c'est le robot là attendez
n'essayez pas de me faire croire que
jean françois piège est un humain
quelqu'un qui se tient naturellement
comme ça et forcément une intelligence
artificielle et cuisson c'est un coup de
coeur
et qui vous prie dangereux qui philippe
etchebest le mec qui te quitte en
dessous non-stop comme sa force entoura
bordel l uta créativité c'est sortir ta
créativité si tu te reprends pas à va
partir c'est là ok mais que faire tous
leurs moyens parce qu'ils hurlent donc
ils font de la merde
donc ils hurlent en même temps c'est
normal de perdre ses moyens face à
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de sourcils
c'est déstabilisant que tu nous fais
quoi là mais hier battu qui sont ces au
début de l'émission c'est contagieux
je peux faire mes sourcils on va pas se
mentir tous les ans c'est un peu la même
chose tous les ans et les mêmes épreuves
tous les ans ils doivent cuisiner pour
des gamins tous les ans il ya un fayot
qui décident de leur préparer des
légumes à la con pour impressionner le
jury ont coulé gamin j'aurais fait du
navet avec du chou mariné une petite
quarantaine de légumes oubliés avec une
petite sauce aigre-douce c'est ça ça
fait une forme de poisson les gamins ils
adorent les formes de presse pas
dégueulasse
tous les ans c'est celui qui prépare des
pâtes qui gagne cette épreuve ça fait
six ans maintenant
l'épreuve de la boîte noire ça c'est un
truc de ouf ils doivent reproduire un
plat qui doivent goûter toucher dans le
noir complet dans une boîte géante avec
des caméras infrarouges c'est un peu
chelou en fait j'ai bientôt coûter 1
j'ai tout mis dans ma bouche mais je
pense que d'avoir des fruits de mer et
peut-être du fromage un fromage un peu
fort 1 qu'est ce que c'est pourtant j'ai
bien j'ai bien léché partout ça va me
revenir non horrible dans l'émission
c'est la finale finale c'est super
gênant les finalistes doivent préparer
des dizaines de menus et d un des mecs
qui ont été éliminés avant
certes les mecs on leur a dit désolé
l'aventuré s'arrête là c'est vraiment
trop nuls va-t'en va-t'en reviens tu va
aider quelqu'un d'autre à gagner alors
vous avez devant vous des gnocchis de
patates douces émulsion de chorizo et
une sauce au foie gras préparé par par
j'oublie son prénom là le mec qui s'est
fait dégager la première semaine
alors bonne dégustation
pour savoir quel candidat a gagné
l'édition il ya quand même de l'argent
la clé tout ça ils font une petite mise
en scène ils vont chez les finalistes
avec tous leurs amis ou leur famille
tout ça et ils doivent tirer un couteau
si la lame et orange ils ont perdu voilà
alors j'ai peut-être l'esprit tordu mais
moi de base instinct de survie si
j'annonce à quelqu'un qu'il a perdu je
ne mets pas une arme blanche dans les
mains allez vas-y
ah bin là morange s'est perdu 1 les
100000 euros vont aller à l'autre
candidat
c'est vrai que l'antigel regnault qui
sera pas convaincu ce n'était pas une
très bonne idée il faut faire attention
assaisonnements ça manquait de celles
parfois c'est vrai quoi
et la dame rouge
ça veut dire quoi l'amour ou chat
assassin manque de sel il faut faire
attention à l'assaisonnement
c'est important au top chef ça va pas
changer ma vie un jeu je mange toujours
pareil
malheureusement à 6 il ya une petite
différence avant je le faisais à manger
comme ça et maintenant comme ça je mange
toujours de la merde mais c'est stylé
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de faire une vidéo avec le
caméscope de mes parents et de la mettre
sur internet
et là c'est le méga buzz and on and on
en fait non pas du tout mais c'est pas
grave je voulais juste créer des trucs